beretta tunberg is a hero to this
generation of climate change activists
for weeks he's been Criss crossing
America adding star power to the youth
climate strikes here in Los Angeles she
marched with students to protest the
city's continued drilling for oil and
the polluting effects on young people's
lives and the bigger message on the need
to tackle climate change they're taking
this message directly to the politicians
here in California because they know
that here they're preaching to the
converted they need to get this message
out to a more skeptical public she has
mobilized a movement here I think it's
very important because she shows that
kids can stand up for these things as
well and that our generation is the ones
that this is going to affect the most
and having her as the voice for young
kids is really good Greta started
speaking about like we need to focus on
this now and we only have like a few
years left to make a change so I
actually started to like we started
going to events like these and started
taking action now a lot of young people
feel like we don't have a voice so it's
definitely very important to have
someone like her to show us that we do
matter because this is our future the
protest came as Californians faced what
many see is a byproduct of the changing
climate the terrifying wind driven
wildfires burning across the state and
turning lives upside-down a new fire 75
miles north of Los Angeles has prompted
more evacuations more homes have burned
in what's been four firefighters a
relentless slog in recent weeks the
protesters want California's governor to
do more on climate change earlier this
week he told Sky News the fires were a
direct result if you don't believe in
science they don't believe in climate
change
but you have to believe in your own eyes
observed reality and you come to
California and you go through that five
year drought and then you have this
these atmospheric rivers and rain falls
likes of which you've never seen in
floods and forgive the vernacular but
something ain't right today in
California we can see the wildfires
happening just around the corner
wildfires that are being intensified by
the climate crisis young protesters say
they won't stop until the world takes
notice and takes action on what they say
is a global crisis which should concern
us all Greg Milan Sky News Los Angeles
[Music]